this commission came into office at a
time of disillusionment in the benefits
of European integration with us chose to
do different things and to do them
differently and to do so we put better
regulation principles at the heart of
our policymaking processes to base
political choices on evidence not only
emotions to enhance the legitimacy and
transparency of EU action by opening up
decision-making involving all right from
the start until the end to know where we
need to act and where we don't to keep
our regulations fit for the purpose of
today and tomorrow
ultimately this is about better
delivering what you asked for a
prosperous and sustainable society where
citizens are empowered and protected and
businesses can innovate and compete with
the rest of the world nearly five years
later we've asked you our stakeholders
how we've done the outcome is clear
people wholeheartedly support better
regulation they recognize our efforts
but also rightly ask for further
improvements we will sustain our
commitment in a post fact world where
the very fabric of our democratic debate
and scientific Authority is being
challenged the rationale for better
regulation is even stronger than in the
past
better regulation is now part of the DNA
of European decision-making and will
need to stay there
[Music]
you